want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how to apply the law of attraction to
your life enjoy
when you think a deliberate thought of
what you want
then law of attraction will employ the
universe and all people circumstances
and events
to
move you to what you've asked for and to
move what you've asked for to you
and so
if if if you think about that
there is just action
would be really really hard for you to
reach all of the people circumstances
and events manipulate all of them to
receive what you want and if you really
reflect well on your life and things
that have happened in your life you'll
kind of see
that
actually that happened for me
ah all i did was move to here or all i
did was move to there and
i received what i wanted
thought creates all of the appearances
in the world and thought creates
everything in your life
so it's pretty darn powerful right
and what you think about is what you get
what you focus on is what will manifest
in your life and everyone is manifesting
their day every single day we're doing
it um we are not aware of course
necessarily of thoughts but
thoughts come we energize them and then
they will manifest unless we
cancel that thought out
um
with another thought with a thought that
contradicts it but i remember lester
levinson would say
every single thought manifests
and i just thought that was incredible i
had known the secret for years and years
and years and lester levinson was a real
master
um and he said every single thought
manifests and i was just wow
that's how powerful they are
so
so thoughts are your superpower
to be do and have
what you want to experience and have and
do in your life
and and so if you ask
um an athlete or if you talk to a coach
a really brilliant coach right of a
sports team then you will find that
visualization and these principles that
i'm talking about are a big part of
their training
they have to be they have to see
themselves winning the game they have to
see themselves winning the match there
is a really incredible tennis player
that's a very big fan
a champion tennis player that's a really
big fan of the secret who uses the
sacred this is what he does he sees that
he has won the match before he walks out
onto that court
and and it's the same for
um
for teams it's the same for athletes in
the olympic games running a race and
seeing that they've won yes they run the
race but
what has them win the race is that
they saw themselves winning before they
even got on the starting block
and they saw it and believed it and felt
it and so they just everything lined up
for them in the perfect way they drew
the perfect lane everybody else was was
moved in exactly the right position and
they got a really great start and they
won the race
and so
thought is just so so powerful so
athletes but also do you know the
astronauts in the apollo um
program did visualization
before they went to the moon and
they visualized
landing back on earth safely and so
that's how important the visualization
visualization is just thought in
pictures by the way it's it's it's still
thought it's just the same thing okay
it's just thought in pictures
so if you took a person who had
zero resistance
and you locked them in a room
you know if you took a person that had
zero resistance that person thought
about what they wanted zero resistance
lock them in a room what they wanted
will come to them
the universe will move people
circumstances and events and bring that
right to them in math it absolutely must
because if you have no resistance you
have unleashed a law that just cannot be
stopped
and so you will manifest it will come to
you in my latest book the greatest
secret
the most important practice in that book
without a doubt is welcoming negative
emotions because
when you welcome any negative emotion
you are dissolving it from within your
body from within the subconscious mind
the next time say for example if it was
anger the next time you feel anger it's
not nearly as bad you welcome again
the time after that it's reducing
reducing until
it's not possible for you to feel anger
anymore
and with that anger gone from your body
your body the health of your body is
working brilliantly
but two you will just manifest like you
can't believe like just a single little
flimsy thought and it will manifest
so
getting rid of negative emotions also
negative emotions are covering over your
basic nature which is happiness and all
of this i explain in the greatest secret
i explain it all in here
and so
yeah it's your it's your basic nature so
negative emotions are covering up your
happiness so to get rid of those
emotions is really really important so
now i wanted to explain that to
everybody who doesn't know about the
welcoming process
and now let me explain the welcoming
process to you what we tend to do with
negative emotions is we tend to resist
them so don't feel good right
and so we want to push them away we
don't want to feel them we don't want to
feel fear
we don't want to feel disappointment
impatience and anger and so we'll push
them away we think we're pushing them
away but in actual fact we're pushing
them down
here into our body into the subconscious
mind and they act like a pressure cooker
they're causing harm to the body but
they also act like a pressure cooker in
that they need to release some energy
to so that because they're just about to
burst and so they'll find something in
the world an emotion will find something
in the world to get angry about to
release the pressure and your body and
so
welcoming
is the opposite to resisting you're
pushing them away now you're not going
to do that now you're going to welcome
the negative emotion
so when a negative emotion arises
basically what you're going to do is
kind of do nothing
you know really
um welcoming is just stopping us from
resisting what i do
is i imagine that that emotion is a
really really good friend of mine
and i'm just allowing it to be here i'm
allowing it to be here in the body and i
just imagine that it's a friend and i
put my arms around it and as you welcome
it or allow it to be here
something absolutely incredible happens
it just dissolves
it just dissolves
and in that moment you have managed to
get rid of a whole lot of that negative
emotion in your body and so that's why
this is the most incredible process
because a you will get happier and
happier b every desire you've ever
wanted will be fulfilled and say you
will have the most incredible life a
life free of fear
and um
and knowing who you are and
understanding the incredible power
you have in the world
so just imagine that
you have a friend and you're putting
your arms around a friend that is how i
do it but also too
something you can do is i'll just make
sure you can see my arms
what you can do is just open your arms
up like this because opening your arms
like this sort of opens the whole chest
area
and that automatically
makes you stop resisting right and you
open like this and you will feel that
negative emotion
dissolve
for all of us you know and
we've been conditioned you know i mean
you were very fortunate because you you
had a
childhood where
you were
mind was opened and you were opened and
your heart was opened and that's the
biggest biggest thing
is to open yourself to the possibility
that everything isn't the way it appears
to be
and so even if you can just open
yourself to that possibility just for a
moment you can pick up at all the next
day you can take it all with you the
next day that it's all real and
everything that you're seeing but if you
just for a moment open to the
possibility that things might not be the
way that you think they are
then you have the greatest opportunity
to really discover something incredible
how incredible you are everything is
possible you know when you believe
that's
the kind of kicker you have to believe
but it's not that hard it's really
pretty easy
our belief
creates our entire life experience
and so you can't if i put it this way
you can't experience
anything in life
that is outside of your own beliefs
so and that's that's the case for every
single one of us we really can't
experience anything
that's outside of our beliefs if we
can't experience anything that's outside
of our beliefs
what that means is look at all those
hearts that's so beautiful
what that means is there's not really
one world we kind of think there's one
world but there isn't really
because we're all experiencing a world
based on our beliefs and not one of us
has the same beliefs not one of us so
that means there's a different world for
every one of us
so
all of your beliefs
are held in your subconscious mind and
the subconscious mind is just a part of
your mind there's the conscious mind and
then there's the subconscious mind
actual which is actually higher than the
conscious mind and so we use our
conscious mind with all of the thoughts
and everything that we have our
conscious mind is very present right
and so
to create anything
you are using your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is what
is really what creates if i want to make
it really really simple then i would say
your subconscious mind is what creates
it makes things appear
and manifest things
and that's where all of your beliefs are
stored kind of neat huh
because you have to believe to manifest
something
and your subconscious mind creates
everything so you can see it's all kind
of perfectly designed
um so now to manifest you have to
believe
and
you have to believe that you already
have whatever it is that you want
and the reason that you have to believe
you have it already is because the
subconscious mind
is only operating in the present
it can't reason it's just like a program
so if you say
for example
um
a new car is coming my new car is coming
i'm going to get a new car it's coming
well then it's always going to be coming
right that's the that's the thing you
have to imagine you have it now
you have to go off and you have to test
drive the car you've got to feel the car
smell the car
and just then
visualize being in that car and then
when you do that that's how
if you do that enough that's how you'll
come to believe that you actually have
the car and the moment that you believe
is manifestations instantaneous
so
so
the other ways to believe is to affirm
over and over and over um
so
to be really repetitive for example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful
because when we close our eyes and we
put ourselves in the picture and you
must make sure you're in the picture
and you put yourself in the picture with
whatever it is that you want and you
close your eyes and you just kind of
create this mini movie honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea
it just sees that movie and recreates it
it's like a giant photocopying machine
it will just whatever you hold in your
mind
it will
photocopy it warm into the world
so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if
and for example
if you wanted to attract the perfect
partner
are you acting as if you're perfect
partners here already and so there are
just small things that you can do that
are super super powerful for example are
you sleeping in the middle of your bed
or are you sleeping on one side of the
bed because your partner's on the other
side of the bed
do you have room in your wardrobe for
your perfect partner's clothes is there
room in your bathroom for their
toothbrush and for their things and so
you see they are just little things you
can set the table for two you don't have
to put food on the plate but just
setting the table for two is really
really powerful it's saying my perfect
partners here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it
and your perfect partner will be
attracted to you through the most
incredible circumstances so
um if something hasn't manifested yet
and you really really want it
and i i doubt there's anybody out there
who's
who wants something and it hasn't
manifested right i mean
um i'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there doubt this comes from the mind
and they're just thoughts and
and they're the reason that they're
appearing is because you have a belief
that is saying that you don't have this
already but just don't give those doubts
any any energy and work harder on
feeling that you have your manifestation
because when you believe you have your
manifestation no thoughts of doubt will
come when you believe you have it you
have overridden any other belief in the
subconscious mind you've reprogrammed
your subconscious and then it will
manifest so
just remind yourself that you are the
power
that creates everything
effortlessly effortlessly
you with that power so so just
take it it's not it's not an effort it's
really easy
you know
it's really easy just take it easy
let go of the let go of the doubtful
thoughts how do we break that negative
thought pattern
right so
so you i mean the mind is like a
computer program so and and the fact
that it's on a negative loop is because
we programmed it on a negative loop but
but you know we could have been
influenced when we're children and
things like that so
um so
one of the things that the mind loves is
love's repetition i mean he loves it you
know if you really watch your thoughts
this is the same old thoughts over and
over again you know it's just kind of
dishing up the same old thing so it
loves repetition so the way you can
override a program is to put in the
opposite you know and when you start out
you know you feel like you're lying you
know you'll say something like you know
you might be really broke g i was when i
was making a secret so
um
you might not have any money and you're
trying to instill you know wealth and
prosperity and riches and every time you
say it you feel a contraction in your
body because you know you don't have it
but you know truly because i did it
myself after a while you change it you
you really begin to change it and you
don't quite have that contraction
anymore and then you start to see money
coming in you know in in different ways
um and any and and or you can be given
things that you were going to buy and
now you don't have to buy it or so you
begin to see you start to see signs of
land you know is one of the great one of
the great new thought
thought um writers would say talk about
a sign of land so you start to see sign
of land
now that's what
i did in the secret you can do gratitude
that will turn everything around that
will make you feel good that will get
you off the negative right
but those negative thoughts are coming
from beliefs held in the subconscious
mind
right that's where the beliefs stem from
for most of us they stem mostly from our
childhood
conditioning
yeah somebody's our parents said
something to us we just swallowed it
line and sinker
you know we're like right that's a
belief
and uh and so we take it in and and then
we have all these beliefs that that uh
and you can hear you know if you if
you're talking to somebody like if if if
somebody says oh i believe
or because we say that all the time or
somebody says
i think
behind those two
behind those two statements are going to
be a belief
and so the really interesting thing
they're hard to spot because you believe
they're true
they seem real yeah so you don't think
yeah you don't think they're a belief
you think they're real you know and so
they can be hard to spot but if you
start to listen to yourself you know i
believe or i think or especially look at
the things that you have a really strong
opinion about
because where you have a really strong
opinion is a belief that's underneath
that
so
so one of the things that in the latest
book is that i show how to
um show how to dissolve those those
beliefs and
just really by some of the things that
i've just mentioned
and uh and and you can dissolve them and
you just feel free every time a belief
goes out you feel completely free you
know it's a it's amazing amazing feeling
to you just feel as light as a feather
and actually you feel invincible the
welcoming practice sounds
counterintuitive that you would welcome
something right that you don't want it's
like whoa hang on a minute that doesn't
make any sense it does when i explain
this to you
is that what when something that we
don't want appears we resist it
and if you remember in the secret what
you resist persists
and so if you're resisting something you
don't want it will never go away
welcoming is the opposite to resisting
welcoming stops you from resisting
that's why it's so brilliant
because resistance
is
not bad really
um but
even that idea of resistance not being
fab is something to welcome that thought
is something to welcome
and just welcome that thought
and then that thought
will completely dissolve instead of
building up inside of you and the mind
saying yeah resistance isn't any good
yeah
you know the mind adding a whole lot of
other thought
a whole lot of other thoughts so that's
a perfect example of welcoming now what
i did just then because i've welcomed
for the last four years
what i did just then i felt it
completely dissolve in my chest that
thought
i that feeling that was behind that
thought just completely dissolved and
now that is gone
so it's it's it's that easy i love going
with the flow
i really do because i have found that
life will present to me
manifestations far greater than i could
ever imagine with my mind
and so i'm really just these days
letting everything go because life does
a way better job than me
of i can't even think of things
that are more fantastic than what life
does i had this belief that i did not
have an abundant amount of money and uh
that i was always in struggle and that
came from my parents bless them you know
they are beautiful um but that that came
from them you know we can't afford it
and all of those things so i was brought
up with that as many of us are so the
the one
one that i had the biggest thing to
overcome the belief the biggest thing to
overcome
was the belief in lack of money
and and i knew i needed to overcome that
for the secret to
sweep the world all the things i was
going to buy you know when the money
came in
um so i did all of these lists and i
imagined that i had those things already
um
and
yeah and i wanted i remember it was like
i want a house on the ocean i really
went all out you know that was just some
list
um one of the things i remember is that
i'd always wanted a range for over all
of my life and that was just beyond
anything i could afford
and especially in australia like though
at crazy prices so but still i put it on
the list and i put all these things on
the list but you know interestingly
enough like i did that because that was
a way to turn money around
but when the secret got released i
didn't care about any of it because and
i didn't even care all that mattered was
that i had got it out into the world and
now it was in the world it could never
be taken away and that is what mattered
to me more than anything is that that
was going to get into people's hands and
so
um but still i have to tell you got all
the things on the list
you know it has amazing views out here
of the ocean
um i ended up by getting a range rover
um and so yeah but i did
i did a lot of practices really the best
thing that could happen to everybody is
that their greatest dream comes true
because when your greatest dream comes
true the dream that where you are
absolutely convinced that when this
dream comes true that is when i will
really be happy
the best thing that can happen is that
dream comes true because when it does
you will realize that there is something
missing and that happiness that you
thought you would have
doesn't last and so it's you know it's
it's it's such a beautiful thing and for
people who have been successful then
they get to that point and they're like
they're not happy
and they're not happy because
those things were never going to make
you happy in the first place anyway and
so um but in terms of success
i would say this
that
when you are who you really are when
you're
living from the place more of who you
are than who you are not
everything that you need
and want will fall into your hands
effortlessly and you are actually the
infinite being is effortless
and the way to kind of tell who's in
charge
is whether it's the ego or the mind
that's in charge or or who you really
are that is in charge in any moment is
effort
and if you're efforting if you can feel
this efforting then it's the ego and the
mind and if you're coming from a place
of effortlessness where athletes call it
being in the flow and everybody has
these kind of descriptions it's where
the mind has stopped
and just everything is flowing you just
feel like everything in the universe is
just dancing your dance and singing to
your song
and so in terms of success
when you are being more of who you are
that idea that was going to make you
successful is what will come to you that
original idea because the mind just
recycles that's all it can do it's a
program and recycles and the ideas
that business kind of business ideas
that have never been on earth they are
coming from awareness
they are coming from above the mine so
when you are awareness that is when
everything will fall into your hands
everything that you need and it just
your whole life flows and you're just
happy all of the time now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the good deed of the day this is
something new i believe that you're able
to serve and it feels so good to do
something nice for somebody else so good
deed of the day put down in the comments
one thing that you need help with that
you're working on you'd love some
support or guidance on and then two go
comment on somebody else's comment and
give them some love give them some
support give them some encouragement
maybe give them some connections try to
help them solve that problem even if
it's saying i believe in you that one
little bit of encouragement can be the
difference between somebody quitting and
continuing on so the good deed of the
day in the comments below write down one
thing that you need help on that you're
struggling with that you're working on
and then part two is go give love to
somebody else in the comments too and
let them know that you believe in them
as well
don't identify
with all of those thoughts that are
jumping around everywhere and this takes
a little bit of practice right because
what might happen is um let's think of
some situation you're at work and your
boss kind of gets into you about
something
and that's usually when the monkey mind
appears right when you're upset and then
it's just like great got all this energy
i'm going to go crazy boss always picks
on me boss does this what's this that
and so when you have a situation like
that where the mind is doing that
just
notice
the mind
just notice it
the minute that you notice it you are no
longer believing it
and your mind is going into the
background if you would just notice
those thoughts instead of believing
those thoughts so
if your boss speaks you out and then you
and then you start to have all of those
thoughts and you know what you might be
two hours later you might be the next
morning and you've still got all the
thoughts coming and then you suddenly
remember notice the thoughts
that is fantastic that you've remembered
because that noticing
disempowers the mind the more that you
can notice and not identify with those
thoughts that you don't want the weaker
and weaker the mind will get the
negativity in the mind and soon it's
just going to be like a little lamb that
you can use for whatever you want
because that's all that's the only
reason why we created the mind we
created the mind for my this is my
teacher told me this and i love it we
created the mind for one reason
to to manifest what we want
on earth
that's why we've got it it's not our
psychologist it doesn't know anything
about psychology it's not our
psychiatrist it doesn't know anything it
doesn't know anything about your mum it
doesn't know anything about your best
friend or your boss so just keep it in
its right category
and um and then
you will start to
lessen the impact of your mind and that
mikey mind will start to get quieter and
quieter
[Music]
if you want to know john ashraf's
thoughts on how to apply the law of
attraction check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there how can you build trust and
rapport first
all right how do you build trust and
rapport
first
and the answer is